the center of the universe is wherever  you are  allow me to explain  when we look out into space we see  distant galaxies moving away from us the  farther we look the faster the galaxies  seem to be moving that might lead you to  the conclusion that we are the center of  that expansion and therefore the center  of the universe but it's just an  illusion  here's a random spread of galaxies  sometime much later those galaxies look  like this because space expanded  we're here but if some aliens live over  here they'll see this instead it'll look  like the expansion started from them and  not us  i haven't changed any distances it's  just two image layers and i'm moving the  top one around  the expansion is actually uniform  everywhere in a possibly infinite  universe